hey youtubers it's Charlie so it's a
really sad day Carrie Fisher passed away
so I just wanted to remember her and
talk a little bit about her role in the
Star Wars universe and what might be
happening in the future especially a
Princess Leia spin-off movie so here we
go it's the saddest thing ever that she
passed away but she had such a big
impact on the store Wars franchise in
ways that you didn't necessarily see
from her being on camera like she had a
big role in being a script doctor behind
the scenes like she would rewrite a lot
of Laius dialogue that she felt wasn't
quite as good as it could be she
eventually became a screenwriter herself
she released a couple books about mental
health and her time at Hollywood so
there's a lot out there if you want to
learn about Carrie Fisher in real life
like she talked a lot about her life
growing up in the spotlight because her
mother Debbie Reynolds was a longtime
film actor so for better or worse she
grew up in the hollywood limelight but
within the context of star wars for
those of you asking yes they did rap
production on Star Wars Episode 8 so
whatever her role was going to be in
that movie whatever princess Leia's
story was that's going to be unaffected
they've already shot her scenes they did
say that she was going to be a much
bigger part of the story than she was in
episode 7 so whatever she's doing with
the resistance it's gonna be a much
bigger deal now now that they've been
cut off from the Galactic Republic
remember the first order blew up what
remained of the new Galactic Republic so
essentially the resistance is a much
smaller force than the rebellion like
even smaller than the rebellion was in
whatever the action and plot of her
storyline it'll probably have something
to do with Poe and Finn's characters
they've also expanded Poe's character
because Poe Dameron was a relatively
minor character in the episode 7 script
but then Oscar Isaac which is so
fantastic on set that JJ Abrams's was
convinced to put more scenes in for him
he was originally gonna kill Poe off
earlier in the film but then was like oh
my god Oscar Isaacs fantastic I love
what he's doing so we're gonna keep him
on so in the way that the original
trilogy characters like Luke and Leia
were important parts of episode 7 but
relatively minor just because they spent
most of the film setting up the new
characters now that they've done that
they can be a much bigger part of the
story without overshadowing the new
characters so a lot more print
laya in episode 8 leading the resistance
against the first order but just to
bring it back around a Star Wars rogue
one so now that we're doing other
stories inside the Star Wars universe
that feature original trilogy things
without necessarily retelling the same
stories that we've already seen the time
is right for them to start planning for
a young Princess Leia movie one of the
minor complaints from rogue one was that
you know Princess Leia we know her
impact in the Star Wars universe how
important she was in the Galactic Senate
the fight against the Emperor but that
doesn't really come across during rogue
one you don't really see that like they
just relay past baton style the Death
Star plans to her as she jets away in
the Karelian Corvette to the opening
moments of Star Wars Episode four but
she was a huge figure for the rebellion
leading up to that she was the youngest
person in the history of the galaxy to
ever become a member of the Galactic
Senate so there's just so much about her
life that they have not told on screen
that it just ripe for spin-off movie
territory like younger teenage Leia
leading up to the moments when she
joined the Galactic Senate so she joined
when she was around 16 years old
so some of the expanded universe novels
which technically aren't Canada anymore
have already dealt with some of her
childhood and just like really small
offhanded ways like some of the smaller
novels like the Scholastic books but
like if you've been reading the Star
Wars comic book since they started
publishing at Marvel again that mostly
picks up at the end of episode 4 so
they've been telling a lot of extra new
Leia stories to sort of fill in the gaps
between the movies but that's mostly
Leia of the future it involves people
like Harrison Ford that don't
necessarily want to come back to do more
movies like we have the young Han Solo
movie it would make sense that instead
of doing Leia between the original
trilogy movies you do a coming-of-age
story that would focus more on her and
her adventures before she joined the
Galactic Senate so she's forced
sensitive just like Luke was but she
didn't display it quite as openly as he
did so if you remember the way they
treated the force during rogue one
Donnie yen's character believes in the
force he has a Kyber crystal inside his
staff he invokes it in a way that does
not involve lightsabers or Jedi he just
believes in the force
keeps chanting I am one with the force
the forces with me so you could tell a
Princess Leia story that involves the
force in that way without her ever
having to build a lightsaber and if you
watch stranger things Millie Bobby Brown
is a dead ringer for a young Carrie
Fisher she could totally pull it off she
kind of has that quiet grace about her
that you would imagine a young Princess
Leia would have now she has a lot of
sass in her too like you watch Empire
Strikes Back it probably had some of my
favorite funny sassy Princess Leia
scenes in that movie where she just does
not give a about anything she's not
taking anybody's crap so were they to do
a young Princess Leia movie when would
you want it to be set and what kind of
stories would you want them to tell
because they could treat the original
trilogy elements the same way they did
in rogue one Darth Vader could be a part
of the story in a small way she didn't
interact with Vader a lot as a child
like Bail Organa was totally in on this
conspiracy when obi-wan and Yoda cooked
it up we're gonna separate the children
we'll keep him as far away from the
Emperor and Vader as possible growing up
hidden safe the children must be kept we
must take them somewhere where the Sith
will not sense that presence mm-hmm
split up they should be
my wife and I will take the girl we've
always talked of adopting a baby girl
she will be loved with us so while she
did cross paths with Vader as she got
older it was just in the same way that
the rogue one characters bumped into
Darth vader-like just very briefly very
offhandedly so Darth Vader's off trying
to finish the purge trying to bring the
galaxy to heel while Leia is growing up
on Alderaan just trying to live a normal
childhood with her parents but like
right now Millie Bobbie Brown is about
12 years old in real life if they were
to do a Princess Leia movie after
episode 9 and say like three or four
years she would be the perfect age for
an adolescent Leia before we see her at
the end of rogue one just like leading
up to that moment when she gets the
Death Star plans so I will say you know
what I hope they do is you know because
Princess Leia will always be a big
figure in Star Wars going forward
regardless of how they choose to use err
I just I hope they don't use a CG Leia I
just feel like it would be a betrayal of
her memory if they just started stuffing
in CG Leia all the time like hopefully
this rogue one CG Leia was a very
one-off type of thing like we could
flash back to her as a child but I'd
rather see them do it in a more real way
like you know you cast someone like
Millie Bobby Brown and that's how you do
young Leia scenes but just because this
new trilogy they're working on Episode 8
episode 9 is a Skywalker trilogy I would
totally be okay if they had like a brief
CG Leia moment at the very end of that
not that that's what they're gonna do
I'm just saying that if they want to use
a little bit of Leia to bookend kylo
ren's story at the end of episode 9 I
would be okay with it then but let me
know in the comments how would you want
them to continue to use carrie fisher's
princess leia in Star Wars going forward
now I feel like we're all on the same
page we don't want the grand moff tarkin
treatment like it just almost be a
perversion of her memory and when I say
forward I mean forward in the timeline
now obviously if they choose to do young
Princess Leia they'll definitely have to
recast someone else but what if they
want to use adult Princess Leia would
you rather see the CG version that we
saw during rogue one or would you just
rather have them recast the role like if
we see Princess Leia in another 10 years
although I don't think
it's gonna happen I think what they're
gonna do after episode 9 is that they'll
find other characters to follow like if
they're gonna do a new saga then they'll
find other characters besides the
Skywalker's so if you're freaking out
about them just stuffing CG Leia into
everything don't worry about that like
they're not gonna pervert her memory
Kathleen Kennedy would probably be the
first person to put the kibosh on
something like that so what I think
we'll see in the future is that they'll
just remember her you might see them cut
in images from previous movies and
hopefully we'll get a chance to see some
young Princess Leia in a spin-off movie
but that's not gonna happen anytime soon
like they have this Han Solo movie there
might be some young Princess Leia in
that but she didn't really run into Han
Solo during his younger years that much
so we'll see how it goes down but I just
cannot wait for 2017 to get here I'm so
ready for the dumpster fire that is 2016
to just end so may you rest in peace
Carrie Fisher we will remember you
forever
but what's gonna happen next is is
because Sherlock season four is getting
ready to start I didn't explain her
video that just explains what's happened
so far just to get you guys ready
because I'm gonna be doing episode
videos for Sherlock
so that will post in the morning then
I'll post some more Marvel's some flash
season 3 so there'll be a bunch more
comic book stuff coming in addition to
Sherlock well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my Darth
Vader rogue 1 video and you can click
here for all my Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching may the force be with
you see you guys tonight
[Music]